تتصاعد وحده الاحتجاجات في ايران ومعها
تتصاعد حده قمع السلطات لها
وتتنوعه اشكالها هذا القمع ما بين
اعتقالات التعسفيه ورقابه وعنف بحسب
العديد من المنظمات الحقوقيه يضاف الى كل
ذلك احكام بالاعدام قد تتالوا 15 متظاهرا
وفقا ما يقول القضاء الايراني التهمه قتل
احد افراد قوه باسيج المرتبطه بالحرس
الثوري مطلعا لشهر الجاري اثناء مشاركه
متظاهرين في مسيره بالقرب من مقبره في ذكر
مرور اربعين يوما على موت متظاهره القضاء
يصف المتهمين بالمشاغبين ويقول انهم حاجه
محارس امن اعزل وطعنوه واضربوه ثم جر جثه
عاريا بطريقه مروعه
بموازات ذلك تستمر الاحتجاجات التي بدات
اثر مقتل الشابه مهسا امين منتصف ايرور
سبتمبر الماضي حتى ان بعض المتظاهرين
استغلوا خساره منتخب بلادهم في كاس العالم
فاطلقوا العاب الناريه وابواق سيارتهم
ابتهاجا ولاسيما وان الخساره كانت امام
الولايات المتحده العدو اللدود للسلطات
الايرانيه الاحتجاجات لقد صدم ودعم
الخارجيين على نطاق واسع ولاسيا من فرنسا
التي تبنت جمعيتها الوطنيه بالاجماع نصا
يدين باشد العبارات ما يصفه بالقمع الوحشي
والمعمم بحق متظاهرين
طهران ردت عبر استدعاء السفير باريس لديها
احتجاجا على ما تسميه اتهامات لا اساس لها
السلطات الفرنسيه رافضه في الوقت نفسه
التدخلات غير المقبوله لهذا البلد بحسب
وكاله ايرنا وبحسب منظمه حقوق الانسان في
ايران ومقرها اوسلو قتلت قواته الامن
الايرانيه اكثر من 400 شخص في حمله قمع
الاحتجاجات ووجهتهاما الى اكثر من 2000
شخص